the average life of a particular brand
of car battery is four years and four
months stop
see how you've got your normal
distribution okay if yours looks like
mine and it's all busy and full right
now just draw us off a rough new one but
on it I need you to put down this we
know what X bar is now we do with them
in is they've just told us it's four
years and four months okay that's really
important you know we ground all of this
stuff in the information of the question
it then goes on to say with a standard
deviation of eight months so now I'm
going to look at this and it's gonna say
okay plus uh standard deviation plus two
standard deviations now I know what
they're talking about they're talking
about amounts of time okay so keep
reading with me the manufacturer
guarantees to replace any battery that
does not last three years okay now we
need to come back to the diagram if you
haven't drawn yourself a new little
normal distribution
now's the time to do it I'm just gonna
hijack a small one
I need to know where is three years on
this diagram is it less or is it more
than the main it's less which makes
sense you know hurt that not many would
be you know that that's short so I'm
gonna go about this side of the diagram
but lower than me
and I want to think about how far do I
need to go before I get to three years
so I'm gonna do it one standard
deviation in time just so you can
confuse if I take let me subtract eight
months there are how many butts into you
twelve months okay so if I take four off
then I'm going to take another four off
for months gets me to four years and now
they're four months gets me to three
years and eight months so that do you
see on my diagram that's one standard
deviation below me now to get to three
years which is which actually same
question I've got to go a second
standard deviation does that make sense
you can see I've got a 20 on he's
another eight months so here are all the
batteries that last example three is
welcome
exactly three years well let's read the
question and finally the manufacturer
guarantees to replace any battery that
doesn't last three years now when it
comes to life is it one three years or
is it like three years or 364 days
that's a fair question
but it's not really the intent of what's
being asked here we're not looking for
that level of granularity in detail what
again would you understand what's
happening when you mean to the question
I think a little emerge as we go through
Boeing if you're not following the
question we're being asked is the
question I'm being asked is does it
matter if it's like exactly three years
well what if it's like a bit more or on
the dot I think as you go through the
question you're going to realize we
don't really have enough information at
our disposal and remember a lot of these
are approximations anyhow but it doesn't
leave matter like when you think about
the difference of a day but this
difference will be trivial
all right let's continue when it says
doesn't last three years can you have a
look at my normal distribution and tell
me
where is that on the graph which of the
batteries that are not lasting three
years where are they here those that you
are the ones that make it to three years
and then to the left of those up all the
ones that don't make it right so these
guys over here are other ones I'm
interested in does that make sense so
the question then says here's the actual
question if the light of these batteries
is normally distributed which is really
because I'm doing us on a normal
distribution the whole time
approximately what percentage could the
manufacturer expect you're in place okay
so what I'm noticing is I'm going from
minus to a z-score of minus two that's
where this is right and then I want
everyone down to the left does that make
sense
like everything not just this little
portion here I'm going all the way down
to if there's one which you know is 11
in fact of the day the first day
artifact we're including that as well
yeah
so it's a great question just now we
were working out this little black area
right which because it symmetrical that
black area seems this one right but I'm
also going to need to include this
little slice over here but is it within
these standard deviations that makes
sense
so I can either do it from the fact that
I know what the little black pit is and
then adults like me but honestly I
didn't expect anyone to remember that
two point three five percent number and
it was just a coincidence to me like
that so I'm going to show you how to
work it out from scratch within two
standard deviations which color in my
key is a 6895 of another example if this
is two standard deviations so this is 95
what's on the outside I didn't I didn't
ask the question very clearly what is
not included within the ninety-five must
be fine that's the difference right
but fives on both sides right fives on
both sides so therefore since I only
what is hard it's 2.5 so two point five
percent of batteries
okay they lost less than three years so
this is my answer now